hello everybody my name is Mark Martin
welcome to the seven second challenge
with Bryan what's up yeah he doesn't
even know what the seven second
challenge I do and I'm getting so we're
gonna have a lot of fun here
I'll stoned by those guys but you know
them already so basically this is an app
made by Darren Phil and it pretty much
gives you a premise and you get it do it
in seven seconds or else there's really
no repercussions for vamsi row
consequent ready pretend you're an alien
trying to explain you don't want to
probe someone go Elliot I would rather
not throw someone okay all right moral
in no confusion cut to the chase right
yeah exactly and they go oh okay I was
worried but now I'm not I mean three
things you dad's your house if money was
no object gumball machine waterslide
stripper pole alright then hey great I
can see where your priorities lie name
five TV shows beginning with be good
come on Big Bear the job backwards from
thirty out loud go what 30 29 28 27 this
setting me up for failure there's no
action knows why take up with Danny fill
one eye
oh [ __ ] oh he knows the numbers maybe
wanna do act out a famous death scene go
uh yeah you know what touch your feet
with your elbows well both of the same
timer wanna just said touch with me with
your elbows I brush my own bowling alley
I say something a frog would say when he
wakes up in the morning
ribbit yeah I I don't think they'd say
words at all pretty much yeah name five
things you would not find in your
bedroom go ah leave our burden leave our
spurtin um a dildo machine a stripper
pole a sex swing okay yeah that is true
as of now you have none of those things
dildo machine so just three living
creatures you wouldn't feel bad about
being extinct to go dogs cats bunnies
oh god no I'm just thinking that
pretend you're wearing hula hoops and
you must keep them moving
oh I've never hula hoop so I wouldn't
know if this would work does this look
like proper hula hooping taking the
technique I'm gonna call fail oops one
year what we did not yeah you weren't a
good pantomime room that not dance what
you see I tell ya what three things will
be invented in the year 3000 underwater
homes a Mars car and nope a Morris car
become a human firework baby I'm a
firework oh oh
tell the person holding the phone what's
wrong with their outfit oh there we go
now it's perfect it's perfect
thanks move like a starfish running away
from a stingray
I want to see the stingray specifically
yeah
Fishkin run to notice to our pretend
like you're a video game character
affected by lag
what's the fire having everyone on my
game Andy butter seemed to affect my
likelihood of it then they'll slowly
start to just look never seen that new
line line goes up to me I'd give it you
it's not up to me why I'd give it to you
Ryan that was actually pretty well okay
oh my god you only I got it what a bunch
about it hurry up lo one continuous
raspberry for seven seconds go
I thought her I thought her Bradbury was
when you use like that look ma who's
your CI know what I'll be hoping he
would use your stomach save three things
it probably wouldn't be good to say
while campaigning for the presidency I
don't want to be President I really want
to be president and eat a dick America
all good things do an interpretive dance
now Shumpert oh yeah Wow Oh Syd I've
never seen a birth before I am that's
exactly I photos of my childhood Ryan
put them up on the screen please no make
the letter S with your lips like what
what I don't [ __ ] know time's up how
you do that yes no like make the letter
F all right yes do an impression of a
cat giving birth go meow Nick oh yeah
yeah yeah recite a poem about bees
roses are red these are blue what's
wrong with these I like it it is a
poetry yeah
freeform poetry thank you everybody so
much for watching glad you could join us
for the 7 second challenge thank you
Brian for being Yanks rattling thank you
Matt in lyon and thank you everybody so
much for watching let us know what you
thought in the comments below and check
out their channels in the description
thanks again and as always we'll see you
in the next video